we got I got to talk about crashing I
love crashing and I was very crashing
and I've been a friend of Pete Holmes
for a long time and a huge fan and I
loved that show and then I heard this
really upsetting news like yesterday
that it it's cancelled well it's not
really cancelled we're just gonna stop
making it let's not cancel
you're gonna alright so you guys aren't
making any more you're not making that
we're just not gonna make it did you did
you want to make more of them yeah yeah
we did so what stopped you from making
more of them if you wanted to make more
of them they told us we should never
make anymore we were very happy that we
got to tell the story we wanted to tell
and we do have a an ending and I think
it's a very beautiful I absolutely love
the show I think the show's fantastic
and I think maybe they're all talk to
them I have a lot of pull in the
business as you know we may do a movie
where my doing movie fantastic we have a
clip here from crashing yes let's take a
look at this clip from crashing I only
wanted to be a comedian my whole life
and the thing I hate the most is staying
up comedy hey are you clean yeah that
way my parents will hate you and when I
walk out I seem clean I'm not a clean
comic people think I am and I say dick
and ass and cocaine and all this stuff
okay I'll be dirty little dirty also
don't mention marriage
don't mention adolescence a lot of a lot
of it is about how to listen well then
you don't do that you do something else
or you just say welcome I'm the venue
owner and then you walk up that's the
real Mullaney by the way
real